E aí
[Música]
Ah tá
eu quero ver um sentimento que dá Vai
nada Tudo que Eu Plantei coisa de
manhazinha ver o sol nascer até o dia
clarear e fiz seguir em frente sem
pensar não se acreditar que tudo vai
mudar a melhor forma de se melhorar a
entender que tudo pode ser exatamente
como a gente quer mas é preciso
acreditar em si a cada passo que se der
vou correr atrás dos sonhos que eu
sonhei para mim está presente para
sentir o que quiser
que está presente para sentir o que
quiser está presente para mim velho que
sequer está contente seja lá estiver
está presente para encarar eu queria
estar presente tá sentir o que quiser
está presente para viver o que se quer e
tá contente seja lá onde estiver está
presente para [ __ ] que via quero ver
aquilo tudo que eu plantar Olha tem a
ver o sol até o dia clarear sem pensar
nos acreditar que tudo [ __ ]
O melhor é entender que tudo pode ser
exatamente como a gente quer mas é
preciso acreditar
eu vou correr atrás de um sonho que eu
sonhei para mim está presente para
sentir o que quiser que está presente
para sentir o que quiser que está
presente para viver o que secar está
contente seja lá onde estiver está
presente para caro que via está presente
para sentir o que quiser está presente
da viver o que se quer está contente
seja lá onde estiver está presente pegar
o que vier está presente paciente está
presente para sempre presente para dizer
a vida está presente declarar está
presente para sentir a presente para se
dar presente para avisar a gente para
ficar poder estar presente ver claro né
é o melhor lugar do mundo aqui e agora o
melhor lugar do mundo é aqui e agora o
melhor lugar do mundo aqui e agora o
melhor lugar do mundo aqui ó